the world crime fighting body interpol
has elected a controversial new
president human rights groups accused
general ahmad nasir al-rasi of being
involved in torture and arbitrary
detentions in the united arab emirates
he's also facing criminal complaints in
five countries al-raysi will serve a
four-year term
and did you have a feeling ali ahmad was
imprisoned in the united arab emirates
for about 20 days
but the trauma lasts forever
he was arrested and tortured he says for
wearing a qatar shirt at a football
match
my teeth is fall down because of punch
and i've been stopped inside prison i
was very lucky to survive
i've been introduced days and nights
all the time handcuffed facing the wall
and it was very very hard tough time for
me
matthew hedges has a similar story the
brit was in the united arab emirates
researching his phd when he was detained
he was accused of spying and held in
solitary confinement for nearly seven
months
they forced a cocktail of medication on
me
which was a tranquilizer medication to
keep me calm and sleepy
and
they threaten me with physical violence
it's all very unsettling
i tried to commit suicide a few months
later
both hedges and ahmad blame this man for
their ordeal
ahmed nasser al-raysi is the inspector
general at the ua east interior ministry
and as such he is also responsible for
what happens inside the country's
presence
hedges and ahmad want already to be
tried in court
instead he just became the new head of
interpol
there is no reasonable
conclusion
to suggest that him or anyone from the
ua
should be anywhere near the interpol
presidency
because
they do not abide by the standards of
international justice and accountability
interpol met in istanbul this week to
elect a new president
it's the world's largest police
organization it's 195 member states
commit to coordinating cross-border
searches for criminals
if interpol issues a red notice an
international arrest warrant there is at
least in theory barely a spot on earth
where its subject can rest easy
there were several candidates for this
top job but the organization elected
already
the uae categorically rejects the
accusations leveled against him
interpol did not respond to the specific
allegations
they sent us this written statement
it is the general assembly interpol
supreme governing body which elects
members of the executive committee it
would therefore be inappropriate for the
general secretariat to comment on any of
the candidates
lawyer rodney dickson represents hedges
and ahmad
he filed a criminal complaint here in
turkey against al-raysi
and we are saying that the right
decision would be to open a case
and arrest him for these crimes and then
where there's sufficient evidence look
to prosecute those crimes under
universal jurisdiction here in istanbul
this is what hedges and ahmad hoped for
the idea that the man in whom they see
their torturer
becomes the world's leading police
officer
is unbearable to them
let's get reaction from an expert in
criminal justice i'm joined by bruno min
he's legal director for the ngo fair
trial bruno man thanks so much for your
time what do you make of this
appointment well i think the first thing
that we have to bear in mind is that the
role of interpol's presidency is largely
a ceremonial largely symbolic role so
the idea is that although this is a high
profile position
they don't have the president doesn't
have
uh an influence over the day-to-day
operations of the organization including
uh decisions regarding um
who
does and doesn't get a red notice which
is an alert used by countries through
interpol systems to
track down fugitives for the purpose of
arrest and extradition
but having said that um appearances do
matter and we have to
take into consideration obviously that
um this the head of the world's police
as far as the rest of the world is
concerned there's someone who is being
accused of torture
and we have to ask that question when
that's right and whether the appointment
of alrighty
is giving them is sending the wrong
message that
this is something that can be excused
this is something that
member countries of interpol should be
indifferent to
okay largely ceremonial then what would
be mr what art will be mr al racy's
powers as interpol president some
observers are concerned about him
abusing the organization's powers
certainly there have been certain
reports in the past that certain
presidents have attempted to use uh
their positions in order to
exert uh political influence of the
organization in ways that would violate
the organization's principles when it
comes to neutrality and human rights and
certainly there were reports um
unverified i think
that a previous president from china um
might have been
attempting to do that
but as far as we're concerned um the
the role of the president is to provide
guidance to the organization rather than
being able to
influence the day-to-day operations of
the organization and certainly even
despite the uh election of al risey into
this prominent position
we would expect
that the
interpol's constitutional values when it
comes to neutrality and human rights
will be upheld but
given the controversies around
what mr o'reilly is alleged to have done
certainly organizations like fair trials
and other human rights organizations
will be keeping a close eye on the
organization in the next couple of years
do you see the threat of authoritarian
governments expanding their influence
over interpol
this is a very real risk for the
organization
especially when it comes to the issuance
of red notices which i explained with
our alerts used by countries to go after
fugitives now there's been growing
concerns and they've been growing uh
awareness of the ways in which these
systems can this these tools can be
misused by certain authoritarian regimes
now
and we've seen cases where
prominent political activists and
recognized refugees in various parts of
the countries
various parts of the world have been
targeted
um through red notices redness is being
used in certain cases as a tool of
exporting persecution and this is a very
significant challenge especially now
more than ever
now that syria has
rejoined the organization as a full
member and of course there are thousands
and thousands of syrian refugees uh
living in exile in many countries in
europe including germany who are now
facing that uh very real risk that they
too might be targeted all right bruno i
mean we'll have to leave it there but uh
thank you very much for your time bruno
man the legal director at fair trial
thank you